Matthew Perry and you're so incredibly
famous you imagine you won't get
starstruck when you meet people but you
did is it the director the famous
director M nigh
oh yes M night Shyamalan Shyamalan yes
yes yes well I have a story about on my
channel on do you guys know that is kind
of directed $0.06 yeah it and in this
story I drop a few names so I apologize
in advance for this okay about 15 years
ago when the six ents came out Bruce
Willis won the People's Choice Award for
Best Actor and he asked me to present
the award to him so I did and I went
backstage that night and I met Haley
Joel Osment from the movie and I met M
night Shyamalan and about six months
later I was at this bar this is back
when I was drinking I was with a couple
of friends and M night Shyamalan walked
in and he said hi Matthew and I went oh
my god hi how are you please sit down
join us and he sat down and he joined us
and we sat there for about an hour
talking and I noticed my friends sort of
filtered out and then it was just me and
I'm night Shyamalan for about another
hour and I noticed we weren't talking
about show business or anything we were
just kind of talking about women and
love and loss and life and all that and
he mentioned that there was another club
opening across town and would I like to
go with him and I said sure I'd love to
go with you and I had this weird moment
which I never had I've had before where
I was convinced that I was going to be a
big movie star as a result of this night
because he was laughing at all my jokes
he really was sort of into me I think he
might have been a big friend's fan he
was really liking me yeah and so we get
to the next place and I felt comfortable
enough sort of drunk enough to say we
should work together sometime and he
kind of went like this and I remember
going oh I wish I hadn't said bad
and then he went to the bathroom and a
friend of mine came out to me and said
how's your night going and I said what
are you kidding I'm having the greatest
night of my life
M night Shyamalan and I have been
hanging out for the last two and a half
hours it's been great and the guy at
might Shyamalan came back from the
bathroom and my friend said that's not
my night Shyamalan
it wasn't
just an Indian gentleman who looked a
lot like
and I had said to him let's work
together
and it turned out he was a Maitre D' at
a local restaurant
have you ever seen him again since no
but I've seen the guy and we always look
at each other like jilted lovers
I was in the age I had Rachel haircut
the lot oh it wasn't a good period no
what is the name of Chandler's father's
all-male burlesque
I actually know that - that's Viva Las
Vegas